démocratie est en marche et je le tue la
plus forte majorité passer pour le oui
c'est sûr que sa traque deuxième
révolution tranquille on pourra
développer le québec et les québécois à
quelques jours du 25e anniversaire du
référendum sur la souveraineté du québec
nous vous dévoilons ce soir le contenu
d'un document confidentiel préparé en
vue d'une victoire du oui
rédigé par les fonctionnaires de l'état
québécois ce document de 700 pages
formule des propositions détaillées sur
les aspects économiques du projet
gouvernemental de souveraineté du québec
c'était bien sûr en 1995 et mathieu
guillon radio canada a mis la main sur
cette rare copie que vous tenez je pense
vous l'avez avec mona cette copie qui
est montré pour la première fois en
public
c'est exact alors le voici ce rapport
classé top secret c'est la copie numéro
7 celle de son principal auteur carl
grenier ex sous ministre adjoint au
ministère des affaires internationales
du québec en 1995 quelques mois avant le
référendum le gouvernement presque
clandestinement dans la plus grande
discrétion se préparer de façon très
technique à l'éventualité d'un wii et
peu de temps avant sa mort en 2018 et
bien carl grenier dans une entrevue à la
caméra il a consenti à élever
ouvertement le mystère sur le stress le
secrétariat temporaire pour l'examen des
relations économiques après la
souveraineté c'était délicat de dépenser
des fonds publics pour ça à l'époque
un document préparé par des
fonctionnaires et nous avons obtenu
copie de ce document copie de cette
entrevue tout récemment entrevue dont
voici un extrait où carl grenier se
souvient d'une réunion début 95
là ce soir engage l'état s'est pas
seulement partie le seul eto'o qui est
engagée qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que l'état fait silence et
elle je sens que j'ai touché dont une
comme qu'il aurait bien voulu laisser
tranquille en 2004 dans un livre sur la
vie politique de jacques parizeau
l'auteur pierre duchesne il relate pour
la première et seule fois jusqu'ici
quelques passages de ce document en
exclusivité mais même pauline marois
dans sa récente autobiographie écrit ce
n'est qu'une fois que je sais moi même
première ministre que j'aurais ces
documents de travail en maître alors il
ya quoi dans ce rapport des propositions
de négociation le québec choisirait de
maintenir le dollar canadien comme
devise à long terme et établirait une
entente avec la banque du canada
le nouveau pays hériterait des biens
immobiliers mobiliers de même que des
avancées créances dues par des tiers la
part québécoise de la dette fédérale se
chiffrerait à plus ou moins 18% ou 81 à
86 5 milliards de dollars le
rapatriement de tous les employés
fédéraux 2006 lieu au québec dans la
fonction publique québécoise aurait une
incidence budgétaire de près de 700
millions de dollars le déficit
budgétaire à laruns s'élèverait à 12
milliards
le stère est proposé une union
économique avec le canada avec aucun
contrôle à la frontière envisagées des
candidatures à l'om c'est au fonds
monétaire international la banque
mondiale ocde
il est congrès au québec d'assumer les
responsabilités canadienne envers les
pays tiers est de proposer aux membres
de l'alena de succéder au canada pour le
territoire du québec
un cadre institutionnel supranationale
il était même présenté avec une cour de
justice une assemblée en conseil des
ministres bref tout était analysée dans
les plus fins détails
l'idée était d'avoir de ne pas avoir les
mains vides
le jour 1 voici un nouveau carl grenier
suivi du spécialiste en politique
québécoise guy lachapelle les tox or
l'état sortant c'est l'état demandeur
c'est en terme de négociation c'est lui
qui est qui il demande et donc ça s'est
jamais la position la plus forte dans
une négociation quelle qu'elle soit
toutefois il faut être très très
conscients de ça
rien qu'en qu'on consulte ce document
qui on regarde ces sites et de tourner
les pierres dans tous les ministères au
gouvernement du québec de s'assurer que
chaque ministère soit prêt à faire sa
liste 6-2 d'éléments de négociations qui
sont fondamentales et ça c'était pour
assurer aussi à court terme n'a
évidemment une réaction des milieux
économiques des milieux financiers
face à tout changement qui pourrait se
produit donc minimiser un peu la
transition économique
qu'en aurait réellement fait jacques
parizeau si le oui l'avait emporté
tout le monde s'entend pour dire que rue
des modifications importantes en vue du
cahier de négociations mais il ya une
chose qui est claire dans tout ça c'est
qu'il y avait de la préparation et carl
grenier aurait même souhaité avoir
davantage de temps
ça prend du temps il faut un plan et
puis si vous voulez rien cassé le cou
cassé le moins de choses possibles
prenez votre temps et donc si on veut
des 1 désengage et ce qui est engagé
depuis littéralement un siècle et demi
d'un code canadel du québec
on peut pourtant assez rapidement ça se
peut pas c'est trop compliqué et on le
voit avec le break 700 préparation c'est
l'acrimonie absolument votre dossier
complet donc demain matin sur le site
web de radio-canada merci mature merci
gérad